[Music]
let's go to brooke in washington d.c
what's up brooke
hello thanks for taking my call thank
you for calling what's up
um
i'm asking for some advice on how to
move on
from a future that i had planned with an
ex-fiance
and the feeling of betrayal
and abandonment i have when i never
really got any closure from him
i'm sorry
it's okay did he up and flip the switch
on you and take off
well kind of he was actually already
away because he was on military orders
um
so
he just called me and told me all this
that he
while he was gone he was away for like
two months and
during that time he called me and said
that um he no longer wanted children
um which wasn't a huge deal for me
um but he also said that he doesn't
believe in god anymore and
considers himself agnostic now
and that was a bigger deal to me
because my faith is important to me um
and so it just kind of came out of the
blue i was blindsided
he left here in january
and told me all this beginning of march
and i haven't seen him since
when he called you did he end the
relationship
um no or he's like hey i still want to
get married i love you just we're not
having kids and i don't believe in god
right now
yeah that was kind of how it was he
um
he said did you break up with him is
that why he's the ex-fiance now
um i don't know i say he broke up with
me he would say he
that i broke up with him i think um
basically i didn't want us to make like
a raspberry rash decision over the phone
um i asked him if he would like go to
counseling with me um when he got back
and
but for whatever reason like over the
phone conversations and texting when we
weren't together just one thing kind of
led to another and um we
like i kind of
told him i wanted to postpone the
wedding um
and because i didn't think there was any
way we could like work through that
um and still get married we were
supposed to get married in july
um
and so
that's what i said he took that as like
i was breaking up with him because i
told him i would like he had some
furniture at his apartment that was mine
and i told him like hey i'll like get my
furniture out until we figure this out
because
i was moving i was like i need to move
to another apartment and um
take my stuff even though i didn't live
with him at the time so hey brooke i
just just met you like two minutes ago
and it sounds like you broke up with him
and and
you might regret it
you might know that was the right thing
for you and be devastated by it
but
all healing starts with ownership
of what we do or what was done to us
yeah i guess like
yeah i did i kind of was the one that
ended it
um
because
i didn't see how we could like make it
work at the time before we even went to
counseling or anything yeah and hey you
don't have you don't have to explain
your boundaries to me
they're your boundaries
um one of your boundaries for being
married to somebody was i want to be a
mom
one of your boundaries for being married
to somebody is
um i
want faith to be a central part of my
life and our relationship
and somebody you were with who had
previously committed to those things
changed
yeah and so they
banged their head up they put he put his
boundaries out
and suddenly you found yourselves in two
neighboring homes that were completely
walled off from one another
yeah right and so we have to ask
ourselves about our boundaries is are
these things fixed for me
or are
um this is gonna sound crazy uh i used
to be obsessed
i used to think the most attractive
thing in the world not the most but one
of the most top 10
was uh left-handed girls who write
left-handed i don't know why i just have
a thing and i love girls who have lots
of tattoos it's just a thing i always
have since i was a kid
i married a teacher like an elementary
school teacher
a right-handed elementary school teacher
no tattoos
right
and in fact when my friends first met
her they were like are you serious like
what happened to you and i was like no
she's really great and they're like i
know she's great but it's that we had in
our head that you would bring home
and we had a lot of jokes that we can't
use now because you brought him like a
teacher right
and so
i tell you that to tell you like i had a
boundary
my wife's gonna be like this
and then i met the woman who is my wife
and that i had to look at my boundaries
that i had drawn that were 19 years old
for they were idiotic and i'd change
them because they were dumb
and then there's other boundaries
that had she said hey i don't um
not only do i not share your faith
system but i don't ever want it
mentioned in my house um our kids if we
ever have kids are not gonna have any
sort of connection to this
you can go do that on your own but we're
not doing that
that'd been a big deal for me
yeah um and i'll also tell you i've been
through
years
of my marriage where i've been agnostic
i think the whole thing's just stupid
the whole faith thing is just dumb
the whole thing's ridiculous and i've
had cycles of being really high up on it
all and real low up on it all and now
i've settled into a place where i feel
really great for like the last five to
ten years
um in what i believe and how i believe
it and it's very very different than
some of my co-workers it's different
than my wife but we have a com we have a
common respect for one another does that
make sense and so i don't necessarily
think that a guy who's on deployment
who makes a phone call
is suddenly cast himself into stone
it tells me that there's something
deeper in this relationship
yeah and my guess is you
you could pull something apart that
things weren't okay when you left at
some shape form or fashion is that true
or tell me i'm out to lunch you can say
no it was perfect until he left
um i mean i thought it was
i thought it was really good um
[Music]
and when he went out there
he just kind of stopped um communicating
with me like he normally would and
so like i kind of did push the issue i
was like what what's going on
um
and he told me like
he
he didn't want to tell me because if
i if he did he knew i would break up
with him
and so like i kind of eventually he did
obviously sure um
and my guess is there's more to that
story
yeah
my guess is there's more that either he
told you
or that he hasn't told you but you kind
of know
that's my guess maybe again he could be
sitting here be like no dude it was just
those two things um i mean i i didn't
really know i knew he wasn't like
as strong in his space as i was but um
before he left he was like oh i can't
wait to like when we get back we'll like
look for church together because we both
had moved to a new state sure um
he's like we'll look for a church
together we'll find a place um that we
both like and
so is he is he on deployment is he on
deployment now or is he just in another
city
no he was just in another city for just
two months so is he back home now
yes okay
have you all gone out
just no he will not see me oh he won't
talk to you anymore okay is he
heartbroken or is he done
um
he we talked for a little while um
just like on the phone and texting
um but
he says that he can't do that anymore
because it's just
harder on him he never wanted to meet up
with me um
because he said he knew that if he saw
me he would just want to like
tell me basically what i wanted to hear
and
say he would
go to church with me and believe in god
for me and all these things and he's
like that's not fair to you
um and so i don't think he's really he
wasn't really done he was just like
he's you know what it sounds like
mentally he could take it
well it sounds no it's it sounds like in
a sideways way however different i would
have done it it sounds like he was
trying to honor you
yeah and i mean that's what he said the
whole time he's like this is
me telling you all this was the most
selfless thing i could do because i
didn't want you to marry me and then
present me there you go and again if i
he was sitting here i'd be like dude i
would have done this a different way but
he didn't call me and ask me and so i
to get back to your original question
you have a picture in your head of
july
and you have a picture of your head of
august and september
and you have a picture of your head of
little knuckleheads running around
and him coming home in his uniform and
then meet him at the door
and you have pictures in your head of
him coming home surprising you and
snatching you away from some
grote commodity romantic weekend away
you've got pictures in your head of all
that stuff
and so when you
grieve the loss of somebody whether they
pass away or they break up with you or
they leave you
you have to deal with all of these
pictures
you had plans with this dude
right yeah
yeah and it's
it's something you can't skip over you
can't run around it there's no hacks
you've got to grieve it
even to the point where you see
something funny you immediately pick up
your phone to text the meme to him
because that's the next place right or
when someone knocks on the door you
instantly your body knows he's on the
other end of that door even though he's
not
right
yeah and i i felt like i've grieved it
i don't know i felt like i um
went through the whole grieving process
and then
i'm like it just like goes back like i
felt better for a little bit and then
just
something small will remind me of him
and i'm like back at the beginning and
like part of me was like
i really miss him and a lot of me still
just wants to be with him and just be
like it's okay i can accept that you
don't
believe what i believe and we can make
it work
um
but he didn't really seem
willing to do that either like it's just
like no that's not fair to you
um and that that honestly is what makes
me think there's bigger things to talk
about here
um and that's i mean there is but
i'm
right i'm confident there's more to this
story um and so
let me say this
just because you miss him doesn't mean
that being separated is not the right
thing
yeah okay and just because you hurt
really really bad and now you're
questioning your own boundaries doesn't
mean that you weren't right
and both people in a situation like this
is heartbreaking as it is both of you
can be right and end up apart
you know what i mean
and
hollywood told us that's not how that's
supposed to go
you know
so
you mentioned something important that i
want to touch on
i think of the grief process as a spiral
and it loops back
and when it loops back and i miss him
i'm not gonna grab a drink i'm not gonna
immediately turn on netflix or pick up
my phone to start scrolling something
i'm gonna sit for five minutes
okay it's gonna sit i miss that dude
okay
this hurts i miss him
yes
and i feel like i've really
i don't know i also feel
like i hurt him
because
i mean he has dealt with
issues of abandonment before and he said
he felt like i abandoned him
um
and so you have some guilt there yes
yeah and then i he also said like
through this whole process um
he's just been pushed further away from
um
what his face what he had and or what
his faith was and and you got to be
careful because now he's projecting
himself onto you
he's making choices about those things
now
right
he's choosing to not see you and to not
have closure he's choosing to
um
to he chose to
dump a lot on you on the phone
and
he chose not to receive your returned
dump back on the phone right so there's
comes a point when if he wants to walk
away from his faith even faster great
he's choosing that that's not something
you made him do
right if he chooses to not talk to you
because talking to you hurts so bad
that's hard to hear
and it's important to go
and i said it's a spiral so what happens
what i've seen happen over and over with
folks is it loops back and every time it
loops back if i'll sit in it for a
second
for five minutes for 10 minutes the next
time it loops back it's still there but
it hurts a little bit less
and it hurts a little bit less where i
see most people get hung up is they
don't want to let go
yeah
that's what i'm having trouble doing and
that means you haven't grieved it yet
right you've hurt you've been in pain
but grieving is the process of
acknowledging reality
this is the way this is
and then asking yourself that scary
terrifying question what do i do next
right and you've been connected to a guy
that's probably a pretty good guy and
he's definitely strong he's got all the
good character all the stuff but it's
been a
it's it's been an anchor point for you
and now it's a matter of
what's next
i wish there was an easy way i wish i
was like a bio hat all that's just
nonsense there's one way through it um
one other thing i'll recommend to you
brooke is you have to have to have to
have other people with you while you're
grieving
grief demands a witness as the great
david kessler says you gotta have other
people with you so you gotta have
girlfriends that you hang out with that
you're honest with that you say hey i'm
just not doing okay today that you text
today's a low day
uh i miss him
or today's a great day let's go out
let's go do something fun
right or i don't feel like going out but
i'm gonna go anyway because i'm gonna
end up having a good time with these two
or three or five or six girlfriends or
whatever but make sure you've got
friends that you're connecting with stay
on the line jenna's gonna send you a
copy of um my new book on your past
change your future and it will walk you
through the grieving process a whole
chapter on grief and what do i do next
i also think it's in this situation i
know there's more to this story and man
i'd love to unpack it if we had time
i think it's worth saying hey when
you're ready
breakfast is on me
and i'll meet you at any ihop or denny's
in the area we'll meet at 10 o'clock in
the morning on saturday it's on me when
you're ready i'd love to talk
and
you can send that in a handwritten
letter
not a text message a handwritten letter
to say hey i'd love to talk with you i
miss you and
i know you're hurting but one day when
you're ready i'll be ready too
so sorry i wish i had some big
fancy dust i could sprinkle over this
one but this one's gonna hurt for a
while
i'm proud of you for sticking to your
boundaries proud of him for being honest
with you proud of everybody in this
situation and
yuck still hurts at the end